for more on the story mentioned at the
top of the show the Vanderbilt pediatric
gender Clinic has agreed to pause all
gender transition surgeries on minors
according to a letter from the clinic to
a Tennessee lawmaker obtained by the
daily wire Vanderbilt also told the
lawmakers that would protect
conscientious objectors who worked at
the facility and don't want to take part
in the controversial treatments
they said we are pausing gender
affirmation surgeries on patients under
18 while we complete this review which
may take several months
the clinic says they've done about five
such gender affirming surgical
procedures per year
which I don't believe
but this is what they're claiming since
they opened in 2018 the letter addressed
to I don't believe because I think it's
much
more than that to be clear the latter
addressed to Republicans state
representative Jason Zachary
was written by C Wright Pinson the
deputy CEO and chief Health System
officer at Vanderbilt University Medical
Center Pinson said that parental consent
had been given in each case for the
surgery and that no genital procedures
had been done uh but they're going to
stop doing that but here's the best part
okay well the best part is that they're
pausing the procedures and that is and
that is going to really in real time
save kids
[Music]
at least buy them some time
from you know being mutilated in this
way so that's the best part this part's
also good
continue with the article says Pinson
also said that the clinic com complied
with existing Tennessee law and would
comply with any potential legislation
that the legislature may pass
he wrote In addition we understand this
issue is likely to be taken up by the
general assembly in its next legislative
session as always we will assure that
view vumc's programs comply with any new
requirement which may be established as
part of Tennessee law
um so they're waving the white flag on
the legislative fight before it even
really begins now you might say well all
they're doing is saying they're going to
comply with the law what else are they
going to say they're not going to
announce ahead of time that they're not
going to comply with the law
well in fact they could announce that I
mean they could come out and say well
this is we're putting our foot down
we're not going to go along with this
um but they also one way or another they
didn't need to make a point in the
letter of saying oh yeah we heard about
the fact that you're going to try to
make this illegal and we'll go along
with it
I I certainly read that I think within
reason as uh waving the white flag and
saying they're they're not going to
fight it
they are surrendering
so again this represents an occasion one
of the very few occasions where a
left-wing institution caves to pressure
from the right
I can't remember the last time that's
happened
okay it almost always happens the other
way institutions cave to pressure from
the left
and especially conservative institutions
what few exist
um generally also gave us pressure from
the left
but it's not an accident that had
happened
okay we didn't we didn't just like Get
Lucky in this case
we engineered this
we made it happen it's all strategic how
do we do it well utilizing a multi-prong
approach
first was the public pressure
okay and that and that and that's uh
involves alerting the public making them
aware and also you know there are many
different ways to make people aware that
something's happening you can just say
oh this is happening
um but to really capture people you need
to sort of tell the story of what you
want them to know in a way that
resonates and makes sense
that's another thing that I think
oftentimes the right we fail in that
regard
we kind of like to just take a
bulletproof Point approach here's what
happened here's what's happening boom
boom boom
doesn't resonate people just it doesn't
it doesn't capture people
so the first thing is to make is to make
people aware to capture them
and then we work with lawmakers to
generate political pressure and um and
these two together create Financial
pressure you got public pressure
political pressure now you also have
Financial pressure because donors and
supporters of Vanderbilt threatening to
pull their funds and all the rest of it
so now now you've got public political
Financial
attacked from all angles back them into
a corner you don't wait for them to do
the right thing you don't just hope that
they'll have a change of heart
you force them
leave them no option
and that's what happened here
now I think it's important to celebrate
a victory when it happens and I do
believe again this is a significant
Victory it's not over though
um
what we can't do the mistake we can't
make is to say well well we want that
let's just move on to the next thing
no because it's still legal to do in
Tennessee there are still other now this
might be the big sort of gender clinic
in Tennessee but there are other medical
clinics that perform these kinds of
procedures there's there are plastic
surgeons that perform double
mastectomies on minors even even ones in
Nashville who aren't directly connected
with uh with Vanderbilt so the fight
certainly continues and which is why
it's all the more important now
um if you are able
to come out on October 21st
here in Nashville 4 P.M we're going to
have our rally we're still having our
rally even more important than ever to
show up and uh speak out against us we
hope we hope to see you there
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really is that's what
it is or Joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the Subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
daily wire.com Spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
Sweet Baby gang